hallo leute ich würde mein vertrag wie
ich defekt in meinen videos nach also
ich mir anders überlegt mal eine kleine
serie zu starten gleichzeitig das macht
eigentlich wollte ich in dieses
jahrhundert kommentar kann fliegen hat
sich die kohlen youtube gehabt dann aber
festgestellt dass ein zwei leute drauf
gepackt haben also in dem ersten video
dieser serie werde ich mich zeigen mich
diese nachhilfe animiert habe dass ich
so aus als würde wirklich auf der wand
gezeichnet da so rumlaufen als erstes
habe ich die einzelteile des mars ist
ein stinknormales dafür gezeichnet und
dann mit edding nachgemalt dann habe ich
die einzelnen zeichnungen mit einer
öffnungszeit gerne eingescannt auf mein
bisher gezogen und freigestellt
dann sind auch schon ein achter sich
bereits das von den partnern gezogen
habe und der nächste schritt ist es dann
eine neue komposition zu erstellen ich
mache jetzt einfach mal 600 x 600 pixel
das werde ich aber später mit sicherheit
ändern dann ziehe ich direkt alle
anderen bürger meines maßlos da rein war
dies erst noch komplett untertitel einer
komposition herumliegen muss ich dir das
mal passieren dafür zum beispiel mein
kopf noch ganz oben macht den kopf etwas
kleiner
jetzt sieht das ganze szenario aber
bevor wir das richtig animieren können
müssen wir zuerst unsere rotationsachse
richtig einstellen dazu wollen wir
unseren kopf aushalten y und drücken auf
diesen punkt in der mitte und ziehen ihn
ca hierher zum hals jetzt wenn man den
kopf mit dem rotationsverfahren wird
drehte sich immer um diesen punkt in
kraft gesetzt haben diesen schritt
wieder holen wir jetzt zum beispiel mit
diesem arm und sie in die situation
kommt hierher auf die schulter die
position kommt der beine ziehen wir
circa auf den bauch oft muss man ein
bisschen rumprobieren das richtige
reaktionsverhalten hat wenn man eine
rotation sachsen oder auch privat point
genannt eingeschaltet kann man denn
schon direkt animieren das heißt sie
kann jetzt diesen armbewegung so wie er
sich normal bewegen würde ich kann
diesen fuß hier bewegen den kopf kann
ich nicken und so weiter und so fort
worauf man achten muss ist dass diese
einzelnen ebenen also die einzelnen
gliedmaßen auch in der richtigen
reihenfolge wetten dass heißt dieser arm
hier muss auf jeden fall über den körper
sein man sieht das auch hier unten weil
wenn ich jetzt diese nahm nach unten
ziehen unter diesen körper dann
verschwindet er das heißt ich muss ihn
auf jeden fall über den körper ziehen
der kopf muss natürlich ganz oben sein
und zum beispiel muss der rechte fuß
hinter dem körper sein aber der linke
fuß vor dem körper genauso ist mit den
arm augen damit man das ganze jetzt auch
bewegen kann und nicht nur die einzelnen
teile von die anderen komponenten
miteinander verbinden das macht man mit
so genannten parenting das heißt ich per
inter jetzt den arm mit diesem lassen
zudem körper jetzt bewegt sich dann
automatisch mit sobald man den körper
bewegt und man kann trotzdem noch den
einzelnen rotieren und einzelner
positionen verändern ohne dass nicht der
körper trägt allerdings habe man den
körper rotieren oder bewegt sich der arm
das machen wir jetzt mit allen anderen
gliedmaßen auf und schon haben wir
unseren animieren der nächste test ist
es jetzt diesen nach wir auf unsere wand
zu bringen und da sich unsere kamera
bewegte fast gar nicht so leicht das
heißt sie müssen erst noch vollstrecken
dazu gehen wir zurück in unsere
ursprünglichen komposition klicken
rechtsklick aufs college und wollen
kamera verfolgen aus das kann jetzt je
nachdem wie gut ihr pc ist ziemlich lang
dauern oder auch nicht wenn das ganze
fertig ist wenn uns diese ganzen
tracking points angezeigt und wie sie
einzelne punkte über folgendes firma
sozusagen wenn man mit der maus über das
100 geht wird einem immer so einen kampf
angesagt und ein kreis gefunden habe der
ungefähr so aussieht als würde er
räumlich auf diese wand assen macht er
einen rechtsklick und klickt auf fläche
und kamera stellen wenn man jetzt ist
mal wieder gibt es sieht fast so aus als
wäre diese fläche schon auf eure band
jetzt müssen wir nur noch diese daten
von der fläche nehmen und auf unseren
mal rüber tragen dazu müssen unsere
mario allerdings als meine unsere
komposition ziehen ihm am besten einen
schicken namen geben auf das ist keine
würfe zeichen klicken um ihnen ein
dreidimensionales objekt verwandeln und
die transformation unserer fläche auf
unternehmer anwenden wenn man jetzt die
fahrfläche unsichtbar macht sieht aus
als wäre der marke schon auf unsere wand
getrackt allerdings dieser noch immer
nicht animiert und außerdem in dieser
immer noch weiter minimieren zu können
gehen wir mit einem doppelklick in die
macher komposition und schon bilder dort
wo wir fahren und der marke skelett
aufgebaut haben wenn ich jetzt zum
beispiel die beine animieren möchte kann
ich ganz einfach die beine zu bewegen
wie ich sie im ersten bild haben möchte
einen key frame auf drehung setzen
einige fenster vorne gehen und das bein
und andere industrien
wenn man das ganze jetzt abspielt sich
schon aus als würde sich das ganze
bewegen nun kopiert den ersten keyframes
weiter und unbeweglich dass kein vor und
zurück allerdings immer noch für
abgehakt deswegen wollen wir alle
keyframes ausmachen einen rechtsklick
gehen auf kiefer im assistent und wollen
ihm eine sehr natürliche und weiche
bewegung zu bekommen diese keyframes
kopien wird ein paar mal mit strg c und
strg v damit wir eine ganz kleine
bewegung haben und machen das gleiche
mit dem anderen bein nur in den gegen
gesetzte richtungen und schon kann's
losgehen
das gleiche hab ich jetzt noch für die
arme gemacht und meine organische
bewegung erhalten
das einzige was jetzt noch fehlt ist
dass er sich tatsächlich vom fleck
bewegt dazu animieren wie die position
des körpers ganz am anfang stehen ganz
erreicht das sei ein key frame gerne
sekunden davor ziehen ganz nach links
und wenn nicht abspielen das habe ich
eine wunderschöne animation wie er sich
bewegt vielleicht noch etwas zu langsam
das heißt ich ihn an dieser stelle noch
etwas nach vorne dann bewegt sich etwas
weiter
jetzt gehen wir zurück in unsere haus
komposition und schon bewegte sich
allerdings hat ja nicht unbedingt auf
diesem weg stecker seien deswegen noch
mal etwas weiter nach links ändernden
überwindung modus auf multiplizieren
damit nur noch das war zu sehen ist und
schon lasst unsere aufgewandt ja was
soll ich sagen dass mit diesem video
fallen da geht mir gerne daumen nach
oben und wenn ihr nicht verpassen wollte
würde ich mich freuen wenn ihr den kanal
abonnieren würdet und ja
[Musik]
die kinder